this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
hey guys it's max today we are going to
be comparing two excellent laptops and
this is gonna be a tough comparison we
have the 13-inch of MacBook Pro and we
have the brand-new 2020 Dell XPS 13
9300 and if you want to see which one of
these you should buy we're gonna make it
easier for you or if you just want to
see how much Dell has stepped up their
game make sure you guys watch we're
going to look at a wide variety of
things such as the displays the speakers
the webcams keyboards CPU and GPU
performance and more let's start out
with the build quality and design the
first thing I want to show you guys is
these hinges Dell finally kicked it up
we have an easy one-handed open and as
you guys just saw right there we finally
have Windows hello unlock back in the
display but the camera is in the correct
position I really wish Apple would give
a space ID of course we do have touch ID
it's easy to log in you can use your
Apple watch the Dell also has touch ID
but I just love the simplicity of that
you open it up and it's there pretty
much instantly ready to go now let's
close these up and look at the exterior
years now this is where Dell really
excels at we have this super slim design
not as wide not as long it's very
compact even the display is identical as
far as sizing as far as thickness they
are very very similar right now this
isn't sitting on the table so you don't
see the feet but thickness is very
similar this is sloped more like the
MacBook Pro it's a slate design so it
makes it slightly more comfortable for
your wrists when you're typing as far as
sports we have two Thunderbolt three
ports on my model of the MacBook Pro and
all of the Dells only have two
Thunderbolt 3 ports but they also have a
headphone jack like the MacBook and this
micro SD card slot if you buy the more
expensive 13 inch macbook pro that comes
starts at $1,800 you will get four
Thunderbolt 3 ports and that's something
that you don't get with the Dell XPS if
you get the most expensive one you still
only have two now as far as the build
quality this is all one piece that is
milled out it's very rigid the build
quality is very good on the inside we
have the soft touch material that does
leave fingerprints more easily
the MacBook Pro but it still still feels
nice it's a very rigid I have no
complaints about the build quality now
personally I do think that the MacBook
Pro does feel a little bit more premium
just because I like the all aluminium
design but both are very very good now
as we open these guys up you guys see
them side by side this is where the Dell
really stands out the whole frame is
smaller and that leads to these
incredibly thin bezels not only on the
sides also on the top even though the
webcam which will test in just a bit is
a pretty good one the MacBook Pro has
these much larger bezels and I really
hope that Apple is gonna step that up
and then when we look further we notice
how the display sits lower and Dell got
rid of that XPS Dell logo and they're
saying hey let's just make this thing
look sleek and really nice and make it
smaller it looks great
the MacBook Pro I don't think Apple's
gonna read it rid of that logo but
hopefully they fill in the screen maybe
a little bit in the future but this
definitely takes the win as far as just
the overall design now the keyboard goes
all the way to the edges we don't have
any speaker grilles over here like we do
on the MacBook Pro and then as far as
the top portion here we have standard
keys here where Apple has this touch bar
I don't know some people hate it some
people like it I use it for the things I
need afford the standard things but I
rarely use shortcuts and stuff like that
that I just can't get used to it there's
keyboard shortcuts you could do instead
so you guys let me know your thoughts on
the touch bar now if we go lower here
you guys see the trackpads
macro pro's is much larger it does feel
better it will weigh better it uses
magnets it doesn't actually click it has
actually improved theirs compared to
last year it is definitely an
above-average touch pad it's usable but
it's not as good now the tables turn and
flip if we start talking about the
keyboards we have the butterfly keyboard
over here much less travel it is more
clicky and it just doesn't feel as good
as this Dell XPS keyboard once again
this is another area duck stepped up
from last year we have more travel than
last year it just feels nicer overall if
you're typing a lot I would really go
for this Dell XPS now before we compare
the speakers and the webcams along with
performance and things like that let me
give a shout out to our sponsor
Squarespace
if you've been thinking about making
your own website now is the time and
Squarespace is the best way to go you
can make a great looking website with
literally no web making experience like
we did it doesn't matter if you want a
portfolio a blog ecommerce or anything
else and you just choose a template and
customize blocks of text and images it's
incredibly simple affordable and ours
has been bringing in new clients for
over two years now thanks to its
built-in SEO tools start your free two
week no credit card required trial by
going to squarespace.com slash Mac stack
or by clicking on the custom link down
below and when you're ready to launch
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or a domain now let's talk about
the displays themselves this is where
the XPS gets very complicated
now with the 13-inch MacBook Pro we have
their standard Retina display with just
over 4 million pixels
we have 500 nits of brightness and they
have a nice can't eye reflectivity
coating it's a great display I have no
complaints with this version of the Dell
XPS I have the 4k touchscreen display it
is actually slightly higher than 4k
because it is thankfully 16 by 10 that
was a great choice and all of the
displays have 500 nits of brightness
Thank You Dell that is a great
improvement and they have also improved
their coatings on the display it's not
as good as the macro pros but they have
improved it which is great now this is
where it gets complicated if you buy the
base model you get a non touch screen
1080p display and then you just you
can't compare between these two you
could definitely tell the difference in
detail and I wouldn't love that display
if you spend a hundred bucks more you
can get a touch screen and you spend
more you can get a non-touch screen 4k
and then if you get the higher-end one
the highest end we have a 4k touch
screen you know the Dell does do 100
percent of srgb which is enough for most
people but if you're a professional the
macro CRO will actually show the full
range of dcpip three colors which is
great for HDR video editing if you want
to do high-end raw photo editing and
here you guys can see that the Dell
cannot show that shade of red whereas
the MacBook Pro can overall if you want
the best visual experience the Dell does
look nicer fourth 4k video it does HDR
but I have
to give the win to the MacBook Pro for
the simplicity and the color accuracy
now I also want to talk about Wi-Fi and
playing back videos right here the del
has Wi-Fi 6 the MacBook Pro has Wi-Fi 5
now it may not make a difference to you
but I upgraded my router and then the
toughest parts of my house the del will
get to about a hundred and seventy
hundred eighty megabit per second out of
250 whereas the MacBook Pro will get
slightly under one hundred so you
definitely have an improvement if you do
have one of those new routers nellis
compared the webcam in the microphone
quality this is what you get from the
13-inch MacBook Pro and this is what you
get with the new Dell XPS it's also a
720p webcam you let me know which one
looks better and sounds better down in
the comment section below now it's time
to compare the speaker's Dell definitely
stepped it up for this year Thank You
Dell they went from one watt per speaker
now up to two-and-a-half watts which is
excellent and I'm just gonna set these
up right in front of me one by one and
cut between them
you guys put on your best pair of
headphones
[Applause]
alright guys let me know your thoughts
in the comment section below keep in
mind you're listening through a
microphone it's been compressed so I'll
give you guys my opinion the Dell XPS
actually peaked the decibel louder
surprisingly but at the low ends it
actually lower the volume a little bit
to make sure it doesn't distort the
MacBook Pro stays consistent and overall
it is louder than the sound quality is
better and for Thunderbolt 3 port model
also has better speakers so either way
the MacBook Pro does take the win but
compared to last year where the Dell XPS
got completely slaughtered does made a
good improvement and for most people
these speakers are more than good enough
now let's go ahead and talk about
something else where the dell has a lead
and that is you can actually swap out
the SSD so here's some shots for you
guys if you want so you can pull that
out if you get the bass 256 gig model
and the bass 1 is actually a good
fastest SD I have the 512 right over
here and you can pop in a 1 terabyte or
2 terabyte that is excellent with the
MacBook Pro now not only is the RAM
soldered like it is on the XPS but your
SSD is soldered so you have to make sure
you make a good choice out of the get-go
now finally let's talk about performance
all of the current 13-inch MacBook Pros
use in cells 8th generation processors
but get variants of them which make it
stay kind of competitive whereas all of
the new XPS is used the 10th generation
processors two generations newer they
are 10 nanometer processors which help
with efficiency and if we compare the
base model I fives you're looking at we
have 907 single core compared to 1220
that is a massive difference in
multi-core we have about 300 points or
so more score with the base model XPS
now the multi-core doesn't matter that
much they both have eight gigs of RAM
but the single core that really makes a
noticeable makes it nice and snappy for
day to day simple tasks opening up
different apps the 10 generations are
really good there now as far as the
graphics if you get the base models
you're actually looking at very similar
performance we have 5704 compared to 58
forty-eight that's because the base
model uses the g1 graphics which are not
really that powerful
now with the MacBook Pros if you go
ahead and step up to the eighteen
hundred dollar model or even pay extra
for their higher end ones the
performance doesn't get damaged better
multi-core gets actually closer to this
but still not as good as the base model
single core is still far off and on the
graphics front we go from about fifty
seven hundred up to about seventy seven
hundred or so a decent bump but we
typically don't tell people to spend the
extra money
whereas with Adel when you go for the i7
you not only get better CPU performance
as you guys see here we jump up to four
thousand seven hundred and the single
core is still kind of similar you also
get much better graphics performance we
have ten thousand four hundred and
twenty and that means that a lot of
different apps that are starting to use
graphics acceleration it helps out there
and if you want to gain this graphics
card in here even though it's not meant
for gaming you can get about fifty
percent higher frame rates for example
in Unigine heaven it did quite a bit
better than the MacBook Pro now let's go
ahead and talk about prices now this is
where things also get a little
interesting the Mac Pro has been out for
a while you can get some good discounts
on it whereas the Dell it is just coming
out and there are no discounts but in a
few months there will be all of links
are both in a video description so you
guys can compare the current prices when
you guys are watching the video we're
looking at the regular prices the XPS
seems like a better value and then of
course we are gonna have some sales on
that after a few months but keep in mind
there are also sales where you can
actually get the higher end for
thunderbolt port model for a lower price
in the XPS with the best discounts from
B and H so it really is kind of a wash
price-wise because of the discounts that
are now available for the MacBook Pro
and overall if I had to decide which one
of these would I buy honestly for me you
guys know I love mac OS and that keeps
me tied into the Mac ecosystem the dough
I really like the keyboard the speakers
are improved
I like the improved display all those
things have been improved I love they
could swap out the SS
I like the extra performance and just
overall as a laptop I think this gives
you a better value in that way if you
don't care about which operating system
you're using the graphics for gaming can
actually do some light gaming on it as
well it is an excellent laptop nice thin
slim it is a very good laptop so for now
this is the better laptop but if you
need Mac OS you're gonna be sticking
with a micro Pro and that is me when we
get a new 14 inch macro Pro if that
comes out if we will do another
comparison make sure you guys are
subscribed by clicking that little
circle above and if you guys want to see
another video on the XPS or the Mac with
pros you guys can click right over there
this has been maxed and I'll see you in
the next video
[Music]